make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and
yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is rob and for
today's installment of our beyond omega
level series which we haven't done in a
little while
uh we are once again going to head over
to marvel's ultimate universe and
discuss a character that was actually
far more powerful in the ultimate
universe than in the main marvel
universe
this version of loki was created by mark
miller and brian hitch and first
appeared in
ultimates 2 number 1 in 2015. now while
the main universe version of loki is the
adopted son of odin in the ultimate
universe loki is actually odin's
biological son
loki's mother is the frost giant for
body and he was born as part of an
attempted peace negotiation
between asgard and jotunheim the home of
the frost giants which had actually been
at war with one another for a thousand
years the war raged on however with loki
fighting for asgard along with his
brothers thor and balder who together
made up the warriors 3. now after asgard
won the war loki would turn on them
after his mother who was being held
captive by odin asked loki to retrieve
the nornstones for now the nornstones
were 24 stones made of the same material
as mjolnir and were avatars of odin's
power when assembled in the proper order
they could open dimensional gateways
between rounds and loki agrees to
retrieve the stones and in doing so
is confronted by and kills his
half-brother balder now following the
murder of his brother loki is banished
from asgard and ends up on earth
disguised as a super villain baron zemo
loki then led a coalition of frost
giants and germans in an attack on
asgard killing heimdall in the process
but a combination of heimdall's blood
which his soldiers consumed and the
nornstones greatly bolstered the
strength of loki's forces but he was
ultimately defeated by odin who banished
him to a prison realm known as the room
without doors
and so loki remained in the room without
doors for 60 years but would eventually
escape when one of his soldiers helmet
zemo
used the power of the nornstones to open
a gateway into the room which freed loki
now loki would continue to antagonize
his brother thor and the ultimates the
ultimate universe's version of the
avengers and tried to bring about world
war three
along with the liberators a team of
supervillains sponsored by several world
governments
and so after the ultimates defeated the
liberators loki tried to carry on the
mission of destroying the ultimates
himself and in doing so
summoned an army of monsters from asgard
but his plans were thwarted by odin who
sent asgardian warriors to repel the
attack
and also stripped loki of most of his
powers loki was then imprisoned by odin
once more but after he escaped he was
sent to hell by hella now somehow loki
either escapes or is freed from hell but
he dies in a siege of asgard by the
children of tomorrow a group of
superpower soldiers led by the maker the
ultimate universe's version of reed
richards and so not only does ultimate
loki's origin differ significantly from
the classic version but his powers do as
well although ultimate loki is a devious
trickster in much the same way that his
616 counterpart is his power set is far
beyond
anything that the main marvel universe
loki could ever hope to achieve
ultimate loki possesses superhuman
strength and has been able to harm his
brother
thor in a sparring session where he also
proved himself to be a capable fighter
he's skilled in a variety of weapons but
his weapon of choice is a bow and arrow
which he uses to slay multiple frost
giants
heimdall and balder loki also possesses
superhuman speed and durability and just
to get a sense of how durable he is he
survived beatings from thor
as well as surviving thor's lightning
attacks but what really sets loki apart
from the version that we're probably
more familiar with
is his reality warping ability this is
described as an ability to shuffle
time and space but in effect it's
basically just reality warping for
instance
on one occasion thor's in a restaurant
talking to volksdag about loki who thor
dismisses as not being a major threat
because every time they battle thor
always wins now volstagg tells thor
that this time is different and that
loki is moving the scenery around them
and rewriting reality itself
moments later a waiter comes up to thor
and says that the restaurant's other
patrons are concerned
because thor has been talking to himself
for five minutes thor is then taken
aback
and looks up to see that volstag is no
longer at the table and the waiter
confirms that he was never there at all
and so soon after this
loki creates a new persona for himself
taking the form of gunnar goldman who
claims to be part of the norwegian super
soldier program
and furthermore claims that thor is not
the god he claims to be but a product of
that super soldier program this of
course was a ruse designed to convince
the ultimates that thor is insane
and turn them against him but despite
thor's insistence that loki is
responsible for his ruse by shuffling
time and space the ultimates
indeed begin to question his sanity on
another occasion loki uses his reality
warping abilities to alter security tape
footage to make it appear that captain
america is responsible for the murder of
hawkeye's family when in reality
it was black widow who killed him now
loki is also able to bestow powers on
others as he did with valkyrie and the
rest of the ultimate defenders who in
turn
pledge their allegiance to loki loki's
capable of size manipulation of himself
and others
being able to either shrink to tiny
proportions or grow to massive ones he
can also create multiple copies of
himself
shapeshift and claims that he can alter
the color of the sun and the sky
he can teleport to anywhere he wants and
has displayed the ability to summon
various mythical creatures such as
serpents giants trolls and giant wolves
there are limitations to loki's power
though
as using them alerts odin to his
presence which loki tries to avoid at
all costs
as odin is capable of removing his
powers from him now it's also been
suggested that loki's powers are rooted
in sorcery
instead of outright reality warping as
his power has been shown to grow
and diminish at various points and so he
has been written somewhat inconsistently
and of course
any time he tangles with thor he usually
loses despite his reality warping
ability
because that's just how things work when
you fight four more often than not
but still ultimate loki has displayed
some incredibly
impressive feats and is vastly more
powerful than the 616 version
even counting the time that loki briefly
became the sorcerer supreme but even
still it's kind of surprising that loki
didn't do more with his powers than he
did because you would think he'd do some
crazy stuff or at least get a few more
victories and he did as most of his
plans ultimately ended up in failure but
that's the plight of super villains
they're always just being thwarted by
the good guys
but let me know what you guys think down
in the comments section if you guys are
new here to comments explain
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
[Music]
peace
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
spectrum
[Applause]
[Music]
youtube
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
me
[Applause]
[Music]
you